the Joe Rogan experience and then it
talked about how Malibu Barbie like
what's the first one that like have the
eyes stare right at you so it was like
more sexual or somewhat interesting [ __ ]
dude
you don't wanna you know I mean that's
the thing about those dolls and all that
stuff is like you're you're putting
something in the kids head this is what
an adult looks like but I guess you're
doing the same thing with he-man right
oh yeah like you're putting on the boy's
head then he gets in the mirror yeah
that's why people flex their Italian
horn looking at their muscles no like
what in comparison to he-man I'm nothing
you know that's the argument to about
the rock or anybody who's like some
beautiful muscular creature like that
it's like how the [ __ ] do you aspire to
that but guys don't complain about that
[ __ ] like you don't hear a lot of
complaints about male positive body
image you know you don't hear that like
people don't care if guys are fat guys
feel sad because they're fat nobody
gives a [ __ ] thank God but you know what
I mean I mean it's like it's a big deal
like fat shaming men wells last time
anybody got accused of fat shaming a guy
it's always a woman right it's always if
you're a fat shaming it's implied you're
fat shaming a woman because the only
ones who care Tom at birth that was a
different kind of fat time they got
locked up and because people found it a
target like oh let's let's figure out
what we can say here oh it's fat shaming
but just genuinely unlike unlike with
without ever being requested by someone
like give you just on your own you
decided to say that's fat shaming look
you saw it you pointed out and it became
an issue about a public event or a
public person or a public celebrity said
I'm being fat shamed and it was a man
[ __ ] never does it means that it
hasn't happened maybe it hasn't either I
have been paying attention but I can't
imagine that some guy would [ __ ]
complain she has a gut and someone's fat
shaming him
publicly he would just look at that gun
and go [ __ ] the right I gotta stop
meeting you know like the time and birth
thing people really did think they were
serious that's where it got weird like
people would get angry at Bert or angry
at Tom yeah
their pick sides Bert was telling me
about this the other day he hired me to
like drive him on this golf cart for
this marathon like in between taking
Instagram photos he brand 533 that's
pretty good pretty good
no it's an hour slower than Oprah but
hey he's fat and he drinks a lot which
interesting is like the guy that the
first place guy the guy that actually
you know one it was like two and a half
hours and says no no no one's is it that
that's can't be yeah and it's just an
interest so it's two hours that they
can't break right and can't break two
hours yeah I was thinking they like that
Stu here so like two 1146 well that's
what he did yeah oh my god Sam what Bert
was five and a half see that's insane
runs so so fast
that's insane I can't have tried to run
that fast for like a mile it's oh my god
I didn't know they did it that fast I
thought like I thought it was around if
I was guessing when you said 230 or
whatever the [ __ ] we thought it was I
would be like that's like a world record
or some [ __ ] what did it used to be
didn't used to be three hours like a big
deal I know I was like a three minute
mile is the big deal no four-minute mile
right then easiest came out and changed
it easy has changed the game you got so
much more bounced how about does go back
to the world-record marathon world
record Boston Marathon 1980 I have a
feeling it's like in the threes
probably is I mean just would be world
record Boston Marathon that's a stupid
thing to say it's the Boston Marathon
record who's who won it someone in 2011
203 Oh - yeah but that's 2011 I want to
go down 1980 right but not the record
just like what is the result from 1980
Boston Marathon result 1980
I wanted I want to say that was probably
the last time I paid attention because
uh I lived in Boston I don't give a [ __ ]
about the LA Marathon I hear about it I
go up can't drive there now but I'm not
like oh what a smart things people are
all running on the street I think the
reason why you're remembering that is
because that's when the woman faked the
time oh that's right that's right I
forgot about her oh my god that was 1980
that's right was she hopped on the tee
yeah and they busted her people saw her
on the tee
what was her time well just you're a
terrible person to talk to about this
because you keep taking us down more and
more rabbit holes okay
Boston Marathon results 1980s put an ass
on that [ __ ] 1979 results here we go
here we go okay what do we got twenty
Wow
okay I'm way off what's still 10 Genesee
six the third place 247 the first place
women's top results so women do it in
247 the man was doing in 220 220 is
[ __ ] crazy that is so crazy you can
run 26 miles in two hours and 20 minutes
woof I would imagine that would been
like a world record I'm so off you know
but it's I wonder what they weigh you
know that's another thing like Burt
what's really impressive is how big Burt
is where it's like 350 pounds more than
that probably probably yeah he's 800
pounds and he's running out there
[Applause]